gong 2017 and gong 2020
one that has appeared on the big screen
while the other is yet to come
but we have seen the teasers the leaked
footage and quite a few toy updates that
would make this comparison video
possible
of course when the time comes when gvk
is released this coming year
there will be quite a lot that we will
be discussing again but as for now let
us compare between the two as far as our
research has taken us
we are also going to include some info
about gong from the birth of gong comics
as well
as this one is crucial in many aspects
when we get from the 2017 ape
to the 2021 version so here it goes
the first comparison of course is size
2017 kong stands over 100 feet tall
and this beast is a primate of such size
and ferocity that
his very existence rewrites every
chapter of evolutionary theory
kong is an entirely new super species
beyond any existing
category of life on earth he is
worshipped as a god by the ewe and
inspired a culture
of reverence among the indigenous people
of skull island
gong 2021 as we have seen in the leaked
footage is almost at par with godzilla
in size
growing exponentially from 2017 at 104
feet
and birth of kong when he was around 200
feet
in this upcoming movie we expect god to
be over 350 feet tall
the same ratio as in the earlier 1962
movie when he was lit just a little bit
shorter than godzilla
again with size we have weight the thing
about this is that when
gong 2017 was seen in skull island movie
he was officially stated to be 158 tons
but that is just lazy estimates given by
legendary in actuality if we take king
kong 1962 for instance
from the king kong vs godzilla movie he
was 45 meters and weighed 25 000 tons
so kong 2017 being 13 meters shorter
would actually be between 10 000 and 15
000 tons
so let's see godzilla 2019 he weighs
approximately a hundred thousand tons
therefore this future kong would have to
closely match up in weight
if he is going to even move the g-man
during a fight so let's say with a 350
feet height kong would be close to 80
000
tons now let's look at his face
gong in 1973 was an adult and yet to
fully mature both in size
musculature and facial features this
kong has a long sharp teeth a small
beard
and bulging eyebrows he is made to
closely resemble a gorilla in all ways
possible
and indeed he looks ferocious in 2021
kong however having matured in the last
50 years
has even bigger teeth duh and especially
the canines relative to the size of his
face
he also has grown a viking-like beard
and looks to be more ferocious and with
scars on his face
so comparing the two the 2021 kong looks
to have had a lot of
hard battles over the years and
therefore more hardened in expression
so again kong is shown to be an
intelligent being
for he can differentiate between his
allies from his enemies
he also takes advantage from his
surroundings while fighting and can use
tools as
many primates do which he shows by using
boulders
and trees as weapons he even used a
chain to tear off the propeller from a
wrecked ship and use it to grapple and
hack the skull devil at one point of
time and also tried to strangle it with
a chain
well the leaked images of toys shows
kong 2021
wielding something that could change the
types of battle
against godzilla that is him using a
battle maze
or an axe made from one of godzilla's
dorsal plates
this shows that 2021 kong is more
innovative in
using weapons than 2017. lastly we are
going to
look at his build his musculature while
com 2017 does look imposing and muscular
compared to gvk kong he is like an
athlete like a michael phelps
versus 2021 brock lesnar and after all
this time it looks like he has hit the
gym
the increase in mars is necessary if he
is to ever stand a chance against the
king of the monsters
especially since he has no special
ability or ranged attack
no beam or laser just his width and his
body
anyway this brings us to the end of this
comparison between kong 2017 and kong
2021
do hit that like and subscribe button
for more more subverse videos
also the notification bell take care